reject Nation got Transformers trailer
we are here today to check out rise of
the Beast John how are you I am I'm feeling
beastly how are you good I'm sweaty from doing
cargo came back here throwing a flannel
of Beanie to hide the fact that I'm all
sweaty and just came back from doing cardio
thing and now I didn't bring any attention
to it that's how you get a job done ladies
and gentlemen leave a like let's get to it
for millions of years foreign
ers
Basketball stand down I'm not the
one to fear Pride the darkness coming
there are beast wars coming
look at those concept art from uh another movie
last night I think Bumblebee it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving classic
whoa nicely done
Transformers killing cops
look how cool this looks oh
damn it looks like the cartoons
your past
the Rhino future
you've never faced anything like this
that's a great life
not bad
that looks awesome nice
RC looks sick all righty wow well that looks
really cool yeah so this movie three nothing
at the other day it's not gonna be I mean I
heard that the uh Decepticons are gonna be
factoring in in some way because it's supposed to
be taking place I believe in like the mid 90s 94
or something like that that's gonna be like a few
years after Bumblebee which I love we love did you
love them I love them I love them yeah I quite
enjoyed it I quite loved that bumblebee movie
this looks like a great merger of both of them
because it doesn't quite look like the Michael
Bay movies and it doesn't quite look like the
Bumblebee movie either it looks like it's going
to be that great blend because you know how a lot
of people really love that opening parts of the
first bumblebee movie that really felt like the
animated movie come to life and it looks like they
were capitalizing on that bringing it here and
now they're going to be marrying the franchises
into it in a way you know but come on the beasts
look cool Optimus primates Primal I think is what
it's called because we're supposed to have the
terracons we're just the main villains in this
one I believe the Predacons and then maximals
the Beast so everything about it is looking
really cool of course the generation one Optimus
Prime looks really sick is that Ron Perlman who's
voicing the did they have an official name I
haven't looked at the IMDb for it yet do they
have an official name for the gorilla one uh
Optimus Prime yeah remembers there's gonna be
like primate or Primal but I guess it's gonna be
Optimus primal but yeah the action looks really
sick and then the trailer was reminding me of like
the Black Panther trailer the first one and the
cree trailer and then I'm looking to see Stephen
cable Junior yeah the guy who did Creed too so
I'm like this makes sense yeah there's something
about the Rhythm to it that reminded me of it I
mean this looks like a really sick trailer no
yeah absolutely this took like the best things
I remember about the first transfer the first
Michael Bay Transformers movie like especially the
position that Anthony Ramos is in it looks like
something kind of similar to like a sandwich Wiki
sort of character but yeah with like an ethnic but
ethnic because that's what we gotta do what's the
one thing we haven't done in transform we had a
market here we gotta have a Latino leading man
yeah he is and I hope there's a musical number
at least a few times throughout this movie but
yeah this this took what I liked about that
first Transformers movie and then yeah crashed
it into like seeing that Crescendo at the end
looking like we might be building up to some
kind of cybertron-esque Ultimate Showdown and
finally taking the fight away from Earth where
the Transformers and the Decepticons and terracons
everybody just loves to fight it out on Earth but
yeah this looks uh fun and Punchy and the effects
look great it looks like they're using the best
again of the design approach as Michael Bay's
Transformers movies but you know simplifying it
just a little bit enough that it kind of matches
more with the cartoon like I don't know this looks
like the best of a Transformers uh you know live
action movie that hopefully you could hope for
I feel like having a little bit of that black
panther Vibe a little bit of that Espionage a
little bit of that world-rending Stakes but
then yeah this imagination and expanding on
you know getting the Beast Wars basically Canon of
characters in here like that was the Transformers
that I had growing up sort of is like that was
the cartoon that was running that was most Vivid
in my life so that was kind of bringing back
Primal images to my brain and I appreciated that
very much I heard the movie's gonna have like
Heist qualities to it it looks like it would
while this looks like there's a war and all the
same kind of big Stakes that you're used to in
a Transformers movie it does have a heist kind of
feeling to it yeah well it feels suspenseful yeah
I can't believe how clear it is too like like I
said I feel like this really is the the version
of marrying the Bumblebee and the Bumblebee movie
and the Michael Bay films because it doesn't have
that like yellow machine yeah he has it looks like
he's really sweaty and sunny the best of the base
it's abilities and then you went okay now keep the
camera a little more still so you can actually see
some of this stuff it looks clear and it looks
like the main characters are the Transformers
themselves and Anthony Ramos is going to be a
character to help support that but it doesn't
look like it's about it because even you know
bumblebee was like really about Haley steinfeld's
character yeah and this looks like it's about the
Transformers I don't know sometimes the trailers
do mislead you into that though they absolutely
do I think it's going to be the transfers or the
main character especially with the finale like
how you were pointing out with going to this
big climactic one around I don't see any humans
here it's just Transformers and they're just in
Lego and yeah it looks like a different planet
Earth it could be though I don't know yeah you
never know they'll do that they're like we have
to convince the audience there are going to be
Mass casualties so I don't know they just want
to an abandoned Freight yard or something what
happens to these kids though are they gonna they
should do a Cinematic Universe crossover where you
you get all them coming together you have Haley
Steinfeld Anthony Ramos and Shia LaBeouf Megan
Fox who's married to Jason Statham Mark Wahlberg's
daughter and her Irish not Irish boyfriend yeah
this is part four yeah yeah yeah oh mark yeah man
I'm an events are okay I'm making Transformers
but Optimus primal looks like the [__] I'm
so excited for that it's like a year for Apes
I can't wait well what did you think about this
trailer leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe click that notification Bell leave
a like last but not least let's send this with a
Michael B go subscribe to omnimedia's channel
he's got a YouTube reaction coming out for Edge
of Tomorrow and he's probably hustling right now
to get the reaction out for this trailer so go
support him go watch him he's collaborating with
us on this channel quite a bit lately so go do it
let's go now go to Omni media channel o m n as
in Nancy number one media om n is Nancy number
one media go there right now I mean it go leave
this video go go go go go go go go Power Rangers